demi lovato flaunts her bikini body and  gets a real about shedding her Disney  image I'm excited  the star is on tour in Canada right now  and snapchatted while enjoying a little  downtime on a boat she bonded her super  Fick figure in this neon accented  graphic print a swimsuit showing off her  friends and her booty in a second shot  the snapchats came at the same time a  new interview with Demi and her tour  partner Nick Jonas hit the Calgary  Herald the 24 year old singer told the  paper she had an easier time of moving  on from Disney than Nick did quote it's  a lot easier when you just go to rehab  still Lovato says she felt pressure to  prove to people she had a real talent  and that's why she threw herself so  deeply into music after getting clean  you